when we said we wanted to bring him to
the table i was like well what do you
want to talk about he said mushrooms
yeah
yeah the magic kind of course yeah
jaden smith joins his mom jada pinkett
smith and grandma adrian benfeld norris
on red table talk and they're talking
magic mushrooms people but since it's my
mom it's like you know it's my mom
working together on the latest episode
of the facebook watch series the fam
talks about the plant medicine that some
say is a miracle treatment for mental
health i was introduced to plant
medicine 10 years ago
to deal with my depression yeah and it
knocked it out something jada says she
can speak to from personal experience
what it does unlike just going to
therapy and putting people on prozac
right which i did that too
which that is not successful for so many
and that's the thing so for me i had
struggled with depression for so long
you know i mean crippling depression so
the thing about the plant medicine is
that not only does it help you
feel better but it helps you solve the
problems of how you got there in the
first place as for jaden he says recent
studies that toted mushrooms as one of
the most significant advances in
treating depression over more
traditional antidepressants inspired his
use of psychedelics it started as pure
curiosity yeah the 23 year old added
that he started using the drugs out of
curiosity and doing so led to his
understanding of what ego was for the
first time it was always in my head
talking telling me what i was and what i
wasn't and for the first time i had like
a ego dissolution where i was like that
was the moment that really changed me
you get to a place in your life where
you're blocked by something whether it's
a trauma whether it's your emotions your
ego not being able to express yourself
and then i feel like psychedelics are a
way to
tear down that wall and see what's
beyond it doing it guided with people
that are professionals i feel like
really increases the chances of having
that mystical
experience
since psychedelics are still illegal
jaden says it's important to be guided
by a professional which the table agrees
is the only way some people can feel
safe enough to leave themselves in such
a vulnerable position you gotta wanna do
it this is not play play yeah and you
got to be really willing to confront
some hard stuff yeah
and it's it's very healing and it's
changed my life jada has been open about
her struggle with depression in the past
in fact back in 2018 she opened up about
one of the more difficult times in her
life during a chat with e.t
i just felt like
i needed more freedom the public wants
you to be a certain way
your family needs you in a certain way
your partner needs you to be something
you know and for me that just was never
you know i'm really a free spirit at
heart i really am and i always have been
and um i just felt like
my life had got constricted into this
little box
and
it was strangling me basically
you know it broke my heart when i heard
her talking about it really just that
whole period i had
no idea because i really had to figure
out a lot of things for myself and i
didn't want to burden anyone
of course the smiths are no strangers to
getting candid and leaving it all out on
the table something the 50-year-old
actress told et is important to her
it takes practice to have those
difficult conversations with kindness
and consideration and it's just
something that we have to continue to
practice because if we don't talk about
it
we're not going to get to the other side
we're just going to you know
things are just going to stay
in the cracks and fester so the more
that we can bring these difficult
subjects to light and talk about it the
more we can purify these subjects and
bring them into something new and so
that's why it's important for me
you